This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. There's a phrase politicians often use to describe certain acts of violence. Radical Islamic Terrorism. Radical Islamic Terrorists are determined to strike our homeland as they did on 9-11, as they did from Boston to Orlando to San Bernardino. in a speech in 2017, President Trump criticized the media for failing to report accurately on terrorism. It's gotten to a point where it's not even being reported, and in many cases, the very, very dishonest press doesn't want to report it. Is the President correct? Has the media held back in its coverage? Is political correctness keeping us from grasping the true danger we face? This week we step away from the politicians and the pundits to look at the empirical evidence, social science research into how the American media actually cover terrorist attacks. We will also look at
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。政客们在描述某些暴力行为时经常会用到一个词：激进伊斯兰恐怖主义。激进伊斯兰恐怖主义分子决意像在911事件中、从波士顿到奥兰多再到圣贝纳迪诺那样，对我们的本土发动袭击。在2017年的一次演讲中，特朗普总统批评媒体未能准确报道恐怖主义。情况已经到了甚至无人报道的地步，而且在许多情况下，非常非常不诚实的媒体根本不想报道它。总统说得对吗？媒体在报道时有所保留吗？政治正确是否阻碍了我们认识到我们所面临的真实危险？本周，我们将抛开政客和专家，来看看实证证据，即关于美国媒体实际上是如何报道恐怖袭击的社会科学研究。我们还将探讨
what effect that has on our perceptions of terrorism and our attitudes to what the Muslim community. New research has found that there are indeed systematic biases in coverage, but not in the way President Trump suggests. A perpetrator who is not Muslim would have to kill on average about seven more people to receive the same amount of coverage as a perpetrator who is Muslim. In the second half of the show, we look at another side of the political correctness question about where we draw the line between what's free speech and what's hate speech.
这种报道对我们对恐怖主义的看法以及对穆斯林群体的态度产生了什么影响。一项新的研究发现，媒体的报道确实存在系统性偏见，但并非如特朗普总统所暗示的那样。一个不是穆斯林的肇事者平均必须杀害大约多七个人，才能获得与穆斯林肇事者相同数量的报道。在节目的后半部分，我们将探讨政治正确问题的另一个方面，即我们在言论自由与仇恨言论之间如何划清界限。
Today on Hidden Brain, what our attacks occurred six months apart. They had eerie similarities. In both cases, two police officers were shot and killed. In both cases, a third victim was shot as well. Both ended with the perpetrators killing themselves. In the aftermath of the attacks, investigators learned of criminal records, misdread flags, and anti-government threats on social media. The first incident occurred in June 2014 in Las Vegas.
欢迎收听今天的《隐藏的大脑》，如果袭击事件发生在相隔六个月的时间里呢。它们有着诡异的相似之处。在这起案件中，两名警察被枪杀。在这两起案件中，第三名受害者也被枪击。两起案件都以行凶者自杀告终。袭击发生后，调查人员发现了犯罪记录、被忽视的警示信号以及社交媒体上的反政府威胁。第一起事件发生在2014年6月的拉斯维加斯。
It was carried out by a husband and wife team. We learned this afternoon the identities of a Las Vegas couple who ambushed and killed two police officers and gunned down a civilian who tried to stop them. The couple was Jared and Amanda Miller. Investigators described Jared and Amanda Miller as anti-government and on a mission to kill police officers. On the day of the shooting, Jared posted this on Facebook. The dawn of a new day may all our coming sacrifices be worth it. The millers then covered the bodies with a swastika and a gatson flag first used in the American Revolution emblazoned with the words don't tread on me.
它是一对夫妻档实施的。今天下午我们获悉了拉斯维加斯这对夫妇的身份，他们伏击并杀害了两名警察，并枪杀了一名试图阻止他们的平民。这对夫妇是贾里德和阿曼达·米勒。调查人员将贾里德和阿曼达·米勒描述为反政府分子，肩负着杀害警察的使命。在枪击事件当天，贾里德在脸书上发布了这样一条消息。新的一天黎明，愿我们即将到来的牺牲都是值得的。随后，米勒夫妇用一个卐字标志和一面最初在美国独立战争中使用的加兹登旗帜覆盖了尸体，旗帜上印有“不要践踏我”的字样。
They left a note on the bodies of the slain officers. It read, this is the beginning of a revolution. The couple then walked to a nearby Walmart and ordered customers out. When they were challenged by one person, they killed him too. The rampage ended when the couple were confronted by authorities, Amanda shot and killed her husband and then killed herself.
他们在遇害警察的尸体上留下一张便条。上面写着，这是一场革命的开始。随后，这对夫妇步行到附近的一家沃尔玛超市，命令顾客离开。当遭到一人的质问时，他们也杀了他。这场狂暴行径在当局与这对夫妇对峙时结束，阿曼达开枪打死了她的丈夫，随后自杀身亡。
That was the first attack. The second one that we'll examine today occurred later the same year in late December. Before dawn on the morning of December 20th, Ishmael Brinsley led himself into his ex-girlfriend's apartment in a Baltimore suburb. He pointed a gun at his own head and threatened to kill himself. When she talked him out of it, he shot her instead. She was injured but survived.
那是第一次袭击。我们今天将研究的第二起袭击发生在同年晚些时候的12月下旬。12月20日黎明前，伊斯梅尔·布林斯利闯入了他在巴尔的摩郊区的前女友的公寓。他用枪指着自己的头，威胁要自杀。当她劝服他放弃时，他反而向她开枪。她受伤了，但活了下来。
Ishmael then got on a bus to New York where he shot and killed two police officers in Brooklyn. In a note he posted to social media earlier, he said he was intent on carrying out retribution for police killings of unarmed black men. Police say one of the last posts he put on social media was this. I always wanted to be known for doing something right," he said. But my past is stalking me, and my present is haunting me. The post followed with another ominous warning. I'm putting wings on pigs today, he wrote.
随后，伊斯梅尔登上了一辆开往纽约的公交车，在布鲁克林开枪打死了两名警察。他在早些时候发布到社交媒体上的一则便条中表示，他决心对警察杀害未武装黑人男性的行为实施报复。警方称，他在社交媒体上发布的最后几条帖子之一是这样的。“我一直想因做了一件正确的事而闻名，”他说。“但我的过去在尾随着我，我的现在在折磨我。”这篇帖子后面跟着另一个不祥的警告。“我主要今天给猪安上翅膀，”他写道。
They take one of ours. Let's take two of theirs. On balance, these two incidents are fairly similar in that they've both killed two police officers, so we should expect more coverage because of the targets, because of the fatalities. This is Erin Karnes. She's a criminologist at Georgia State University. Erin and her colleagues have been studying the way that the media cover terrorist attacks and the amount of coverage different incidents receive.
他们带走了我们的人。让我们带走他们两个。总的来说，这两起事件相当相似，因为它们都杀害了两名警察，所以鉴于目标和死亡人数，我们本应期望得到更多的报道。这是埃琳·卡恩斯。她是佐治亚州立大学的犯罪学家。埃琳和她的同事一直在研究媒体报道恐怖袭击的方式以及不同事件获得的报道量。
The Miller is actually killed in additional persons. You'd expect that if anything, that might have a little bit more coverage. But that isn't what Erin and her co-authors found. Ishmael Brinsley received about four and a half times more coverage than the Miller's and he was Muslim. The fact that Ishmael Brinsley's case received so much more coverage than Jared and Amanda Miller's could be explained by a number of factors. Perhaps it had something to do with the fact that his attack was in New York City, while
米勒夫妇实际上还杀害了另外一个人。你可能会觉得，如果说有什么不同的话，那就是这可能会获得更多的报道。但埃琳和她的合著者们发现的情况并非如此。伊斯梅尔·布林斯利获得的报道量大约是米勒夫妇的四倍半，而且他是穆斯林。伊斯梅尔·布林斯利案获得的报道之所以远远多于贾里德和阿曼达·米勒案，可以用多种因素来解释。也许这与他的袭击发生在纽约市有关，而
the Miller's were in Las Vegas. New York is a bigger city, the center of the news media. Concerns about Mayor Bill de Blasio's relationship with the New York Police Department may have added fuel to the fire. The story came at a time when race and policing was often in the news. But Aaron Karns and her fellow researchers have found there is another factor that determines which attacks catch the attention of the media and which don't. When the perpetrator is Muslim you can expect that attack to receive about four and a half times more media coverage than if the
米勒夫妇则在拉斯维加斯。纽约是一座更大的城市，是新闻媒体的中心。对市长白思豪与纽约警察局关系的担忧可能给局势火上浇油。这个故事出现的时空背景是种族和警务问题经常成为新闻焦点的时候。但埃琳·卡恩斯和她的研究同行发现，还有另一个因素决定了哪些袭击会引起媒体的关注，哪些不会。当肇事者是穆斯林时，你可以预期该袭击获得的媒体报道大约是没有穆斯林肇事者时的四倍半。
perpetrator was not Muslim. Put another way. A perpetrator who is not Muslim would have to kill on average about seven more people to receive the same amount of coverage as a perpetrator who's Muslim. Perhaps this is not a huge surprise to you. If you've watched coverage of a recent terrorist attack,
换句话说。一个不是穆斯林的肇事者平均需要多杀大约七个人，才能获得与穆斯林肇事者相同数量的报道。对你来说，这或许并不是一个巨大的惊奇。如果你看过近期恐怖袭击的报道，
you might have a sense that this was the case. The results themselves, I don't think, were very surprising to myself and to my colleagues. The magnitude of the findings, though, is something that we were all taking a little bit back by, that it's such a drastic difference in coverage when the perpetrator is Muslim. Erin and her colleagues did not include broadcast journalism in their data set. In other words, this analysis does not encompass the dramatic coverage on cable news. Coverage like this. US officials believe Farouk's wife, Tashfiq Malik, had been radicalized before stepping foot in the US, raising alarm bells about the fiance visa she came in on.
你可能会有一种感觉，事实确实如此。我认为，研究结果本身对我自己和我的同事来说并不是非常意外。然而，研究结果的规模却是让我们所有人都感到有点震惊的，当肇事者是穆斯林时，报道量竟然存在如此巨大的差异。埃琳和她的同事在数据集中没有包括广播新闻。换句话说，这项分析不包含有线电视新闻上戏剧性的报道。诸如此类的报道。美国官员认为法鲁克的妻子塔什菲克·马利克在踏上美国领土之前就已经激进化了，这为她持有的未婚夫签证敲响了警钟。
And I thought that as we've was reporting law enforcement officials identifying their suspect as 29-year-old Omar Sadeeke Matin as we've said to the US citizen. We should also point out that the New York Daily News has been on a G-Hod against conservatives over the last couple of weeks. The researchers look mostly at print news sources, like the New York Times, The Washington Post, The Wall Street Journal, local papers from around the country, as well as CNN.com. Ironically, it's these mainstream media outlets that are routinely accused of political correctness in their coverage of terrorism.
我想，正如我们一直在报道的那样，执法官员将他们的嫌疑人确定为29岁的奥马尔·萨迪克·马丁，正如我们对美国公民所说的那样。我们还应该指出，《纽约每日新闻》在过去几周里一直对保守派进行口诛笔伐。研究人员主要查阅了纸媒新闻来源，如《纽约时报》、《华盛顿邮报》、《华尔街日报》、来自全国各地的地方报纸以及CNN.com。具有讽刺意味的是，正是这些主流媒体在对恐怖主义的报道中常规性地被指责为政治正确。
The researchers studied these sources for their coverage of terrorist incidents within the United States. They looked at a five-year period from 2011 to 2015. To identify cases to study, the researchers used a data set called the Global Terrorism Database. The way that terrorism is defined within the global terrorism database is talking about the threat or use of violence, the incident having a political, religious, social, or economic motive, being committed by a non-combatant and with the goal of being, you know, for fear, to coerce or intimidate a population.
研究人员研究了这些信息源对美国境内恐怖主义事件的报道。他们考察了从2011年到2015年的五年时间跨度。为了确定要研究的案件，研究人员使用了名为全球恐怖主义数据库的数据集。全球恐怖主义数据库中对恐怖主义的定义是：提及暴力威胁或使用暴力，事件具有政治、宗教、社会或经济动机，由非战斗人员实施，并且其目标是，你知道的，为了制造恐惧、胁迫或恐吓民众。
Jared and Amanda Miller were self-identified white supremacists. They were affiliated with a far-right group. They intentionally sought out and killed police officers and said it was the beginning of a revolution. This would fall cleanly onto the global terrorism databases definition of terrorism. But Aaron and her co-authors have noticed that the media and in turn the public do not apply the terrorism label evenly. That was the case with another attack that same year. After the Frazier-Glen Miller attack in Kansas back in 2014.
贾里德和阿曼达·米勒是公开身份的白人至上主义者。他们隶属于一个极右翼组织。他们蓄意搜寻并杀害了警察，并称这是一场革命的开始。这完全符合全球恐怖主义数据库对恐怖主义的定义。但埃琳和她的合著者注意到，媒体以及随之而来的公众并没有平等地贴上恐怖主义的标签。同年发生的另一起袭击也是如此。在2014年堪萨斯州的弗雷泽-格伦·米勒袭击事件之后。
More or five shots been fired into the front door. There's a male with a shotgun. Where Frazier Glen Miller, who was a former leader of the Ku Klux Klan, killed three people at a synagogue, yelled Hyl Hitler at the end of the attack, this wasn't described as terrorism very commonly in the media. There's a significant circumstantial case here pointing to a possible hate crime because Miller's history isn't a valid white supremacist.
前门被开了五枪以上。有一个拿着猎枪的男性。弗雷泽·格伦·米勒曾是三K党的前领袖，他在一家犹太教堂杀害了三人，并在袭击结束时大喊“希特勒万岁”，这在媒体中通常不被描述为恐怖主义。这里有一个重要的间接证据表明这是一起可能的仇恨犯罪，因为米勒的历史是一个名副其实的白人至上主义者。
Which led one of my co-authors, Dr. Anthony Lemieux, to write a piece then about why we aren't applying this label to this particular attack even though it clearly fits within it. To examine how people draw conclusions about which cases of terrorism should be labeled terrorism, the researchers conducted a study. We have presented participants with real-life terrorist attacks, and what we found is that when the perpetrator of those attacks was Muslim, people were much more likely to consider it to be terrorism than when the perpetrator was not Muslim, and those cases people were more likely to say that perhaps it's a hate crime
这促使我的合著者之一安东尼·勒米厄博士随后写了一篇文章，探讨为什么我们不把这个标签贴在这个特定的袭击上，尽管它明显符合该定义。为了检验人们是如何就哪些恐怖主义案件应该贴上恐怖主义标签得出结论的，研究人员进行了一项研究。我们向参与者展示了现实生活中的恐怖袭击，我们发现，当这些袭击的肇事者是穆斯林时，人们更有可能认为这是恐怖主义；而当肇事者不是穆斯林时，人们更有可能说这或许是一起仇恨犯罪，
or not be sure how to classify it. The problem with studying actual incidents of terrorism is that each one has many idiosyncratic features. It's difficult to tell whether differences in perception and coverage, in cases such as the Jared and Amanda Miller shooting and the Ishmael Brinsley shooting, are because of the identity of the perpetrator or some other factor. To address this problem, the researchers conducted an experiment. They controlled for all sorts of different factors. Volunteers were given descriptions of fake terrorist attacks, including the location, the number of casualties and other details. Holding everything constant, volunteers saw the cases differently
或者不确定该如何对其进行分类。研究真实的恐怖主义事件的问题在于，每一个事件都有许多独特的特征。很难分辨在贾里德和阿曼达·米勒枪击案以及伊斯梅尔·布林斯利枪击案等案件中，人们在感知和报道上的差异究竟是因为肇事者的身份还是其他某种因素。为了解决这个问题，研究人员做了一个实验。他们控制了各种不同的因素。志愿者们得到了虚假恐怖袭击的描述，包括地点、伤亡人数和其他细节。在保持一切不变的情况下，当肇事者是穆斯林时，志愿者对案件的看法有所不同。
when the perpetrator was Muslim. What we found here again is that even if the target's the same, the weapon is the same, if the perpetrator is Muslim, the participants are much more likely to consider that to be terrorism. The tendency not to give some cases of terrorism that label and to cover other cases more intensively
我们在这里再次发现，即使目标相同、武器相同，如果肇事者是穆斯林，参与者也更有可能认为这是恐怖主义。不给某些恐怖主义案件贴上该标签并将其他案件进行更密集报道的倾向，
shapes the way we all think about the phenomenon. of some cases of terrorism that label and to cover other cases more intensively shapes the way we all think about the phenomenon. Erin and her colleagues looked at how many terrorist attacks in the United States are actually carried out by Muslim extremists. The result might surprise you. So if we look at these attacks in this five-year window, we see that only about 12% of them were perpetrated by Muslims, whereas over 50% actually were perpetrated by some far right cause. But most people don't perceive that as being what the actual threat is.
塑造了我们所有人对这一现象的看法。不给某些恐怖主义案件贴上该标签并将其他案件进行更密集报道的倾向，塑造了我们所有人对这一现象的看法。埃琳和她的同事研究了美国究竟有多少起恐怖袭击是由穆斯林极端分子实施的。结果可能会让你感到意外。因此，如果我们审视这五年窗口期内的这些袭击，我们会发现其中只有大约12%是由穆斯林实施的，而超过50%实际上是由某种极右翼势力实施的。但大多数人并不认为这就是实际的威胁所在。
To be clear, that 12% number is disproportionate. Muslims account for just 1% of the US population. But in a rational world, this should mean that 12% of the media's coverage of terrorism would be of terrorism committed by Muslims. When we come back, we'll hear about some of the psychological reasons this doesn't happen. Stay with us. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
需要明确的是，12%这个数字是不成比例的。穆斯林仅占美国人口的1%。但在一个理性的世界里，这意味着媒体对恐怖主义的报道中，应该有12%是关于穆斯林实施的恐怖主义。稍后回来，我们将听到这种现象没有发生的一些心理原因。请继续收听。这里是NPR。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。
A recent study found that news coverage of terrorism disproportionately focuses on Muslim perpetrators. Research conducted by my next guest helps us understand why there's a gap between what we see in the media and reality. My name is Munibah Salim and I am an assistant professor at the Department of Communication Studies at University of Michigan. Munibah Salim studies how the media cover terrorism. She's also interested in how the media can change the way we relate to one another.
近期的一项研究发现，新闻对恐怖主义的报道不成比例地聚焦于穆斯林肇事者。我的下一位嘉宾所开展的研究帮助我们理解了为什么我们在媒体中所看到的与现实之间存在差距。我叫穆妮巴·萨利姆，我是密歇根大学传播学系的助理教授。穆妮巴·萨利姆研究媒体如何报道恐怖主义。她还对媒体如何改变我们彼此关联的方式感兴趣。
Her interest in these subjects goes back to her own childhood. Muniba, whose Muslim, was in high school in Ohio when the September 11th attacks occurred. As even a high school student had to answer questions regarding, you know, why did this individual think that this was the right thing to do? Or what does my faith say about these kinds of actions? or what does my faith say about these kinds of actions. And to be honest, at that point, I'm not sure if I even knew what to say or how to answer these kinds of questions, but I did have to answer them nonetheless. As a teenager, she struggled to understand the shift
她对这些学科的兴趣可以追溯到她自己的童年时代。身为穆斯林的穆妮巴，在911袭击发生时正就读于俄亥俄州的高中。甚至作为一名高中生，她也必须回答关于，你知道的，为什么这个人会认为这是正确的事情？或者我的信仰对这种行为是怎么看的？或者我的信仰对这种行为是怎么看的。坦白说，在那个时候，我不确定自己是否知道该说些什么，或者如何回答这类问题，但尽管如此，我还是必须回答它们。作为一名青少年，她努力去理解这种转变：
in the way other started for. The fact that I was a Muslim was enough to put me in the same category as these perpetrators who had committed these terrible crimes. And it didn't matter that I was a teenager or that I was an American or that I was Pakistani. What mattered was that Muslim identity. That seemed to kind of over-encompass all of the other information that people had about me.
其他人开始看待她的方式。我是穆斯林这一事实，足以把我归入这些犯下可怕罪行的肇事者同一类中。我是个青少年、我是个美国人还是我是巴基斯坦人，这都不重要。重要的是那个穆斯林的身份。这似乎在某种程度上压倒并包容了人们关于我的所有其他信息。
And so I was asked questions regarding, you know, what is Islam, what does it say about these acts of terrorism? And do you believe in the kinds of things that these people did? Do you sympathize with what they have done? Do you hate Americans? Are you anti-immigrant? I mean, all of these series of questions that I had honestly never faced before. Munima remembers one instance several years later these series of questions that I had honestly never faced before. Munima remembers one instance several years later, where she was watching a play, and there
因此，我被问到了一些问题，比如，伊斯兰教是什么，它对这些恐怖主义行为有什么看法？你相信这些人的所作所为吗？你同情他们的所作所为吗？你恨美国人吗？你是反移民的吗？我的意思是，所有这一连串的问题，我老实说以前从未遇到过。穆妮巴记得几年后的一个情景，所有这一连串的问题，我老实说以前从未遇到过。穆妮巴记得几年后的一个情景，当时她正在看一出戏剧，那里
was a joke about American politics. The entire audience laughed in the theater, and I laughed as well as in my friends and this couple that was sitting next to me. But then I noticed that they were very aware of the fact that I was laughing and during the intermission they made this comment where the lady turned around and she said, you know, it wouldn't hurt you to be more supportive of America. And I thought about why was I being pointed out for laughing as opposed to everybody else in the audience who also thought that there was a funny comment.
有一个关于美国政治的笑话。剧院里的全体观众都笑了，我和我的朋友以及坐在我旁边的一对夫妇也都笑了。但随后我注意到，他们非常清楚我在笑这件事，在中场休息时他们发表了这样的评论，那位女士转过身来说，你知道的，对美国多一些支持对你没坏处。我想到了为什么只有我因为笑而被指出来，而观众席上的其他人也觉得这是一个搞笑的评论，却没有被指出来。
As a social psychologist today, Munibah Selim understands many things she did not understand as a 15-year-old kid in Ohio. Terrorism doesn't just have physical consequences. It has a number of psychological effects. For one thing, simply reminding people of death, as September 11th certainly did, can change the way people think. It did a lot of things. It increased this concept of mortality, which psychology shows that whenever that happens, we also then tend to have more ingroup cohesion, which basically means that we tend to kind of stick
作为当今的一名社会心理学家，穆妮巴·萨利姆理解了许多她作为一个在俄亥俄州的15岁孩子时所不理解的事情。恐怖主义不仅会产生身体上的后果。它还会产生一系列的心理效应。首先，仅仅是提醒人们想起死亡——911事件无疑做到了这一点——就能改变人们的思考方式。它起到了很多作用。它增强了死亡率这个概念，心理学表明，每当这种情况发生时，我们往往也会有更多的内群体凝聚力，这基本上意味着我们倾向于某种程度上紧密团结
to our in-groups. We tend to be more patriotic. We tend to support things that are of our nation, a little bit more. So it provided a lot of those kinds of psychological effects as well. Munipa also came to understand why many Muslims were seen with suspicion in post 9-11 America.
在我们的内群体周围。我们往往更加爱国。我们往往更多地支持我们国家的事物。因此，它也提供了许多诸如此类的心理效应。穆妮巴也开始理解为什么在911之后的美国，许多穆斯林会受到怀疑。
It has to do with something called salience. When you look out of the world, certain details seem to pop out at you. They are more salient than others. We generally like to think about ourselves and the groups to which we belong in a more positive manner because it makes us feel good about ourselves. So any group that we are not a part of, that's what's referred to as our out groups. And so that information is always going to be examined a little bit more closely and scrutinized a little bit more closely. So what that means is, as a woman, for me, the behavior of other
这与一种叫做显眼度（salience）的概念有关。当你放眼世界时，某些细节似乎会突显在你的眼前。它们比其他细节更显眼。我们通常喜欢以更积极的方式思考我们自己以及我们所属的群体，因为这让我们对自己的感觉良好。因此，任何我们不属于的群体，就是所谓的我们的外群体。所以这些信息总是会被更仔细地审视和更仔细地推敲。这意味着，作为一个女人，对我来说，其他
women's perhaps, especially when it's negative, is not going to be as salient as a behavior of another man. So one of those key elements is the fact that for a lot of our American audience who are non-Muslim, that Muslim identity was salient. The second part, of course, is that the perpetrators had claimed that they were doing this in the name of Islam. And so that identity or that label became very salient in people's minds. You might ask why some identities become more salient than others. For example, the majority of terrorist attacks are carried out by men, but while it's very common for Maniba to be questioned about why Muslims commit acts of terrorism, no one
女性的行为，也许尤其是当它是消极的时候，不会像另一个男人的行为那样显眼。因此，其中一个关键要素是，对于我们许多非穆斯林的美国观众来说，那个穆斯林的身份是很显眼的。第二部分，当然是肇事者声称他们是以伊斯兰教的名义这样做的。因此，这种身份或标签在人们的脑海中变得非常显眼。你可能会问为什么有些身份比其他身份更显眼。例如，大多数恐怖袭击是由男性实施的，但是，虽然穆妮巴经常被问及为什么穆斯林会实施恐怖主义行为，但从来没有人
has ever asked me to explain why men become terrorists. Munibba says that has to do with who's in the majority and who's not. Think about it as a jar or red marble. If you only have a single blue marble within that jar, then wherever that blue marble is moving, that's going to become very salient to you. Because in that jar of red marble, that blue marble sticks out a little bit more and so I think there's a little bit of that happening in the way in which we oftentimes encounter new stories that are referring to racial and ethnic minorities. Of course the 9-11 attackers explicitly said they were acting in the name of
要求我解释为什么男性会成为恐怖分子。穆妮巴说，这与谁占多数谁不占多数有关。把它想象成一个装有红弹珠的罐子。如果你那个罐子里只有一个蓝弹珠，那么无论那个蓝弹珠移动到哪里，它对你来说都会变得非常显眼。因为在那个红弹珠的罐子里，那个蓝弹珠更加突出，所以我认为在我们经常遇到提及种族和族裔少数群体的偶发新闻时，也存在一点这种情况。当然，911袭击者明确表示他们是在
all Muslims. They didn't say they were acting in the name of all Muslims. They didn't say they were acting in the name of all men. But Munibah's point is that because Muslims are a small minority and men are not, the misdeeds of Muslims become salient to us. This also holds true for other minorities and other crimes. The researcher Shanto Ayangar at Stanford University once conducted a study where he presented stories about local crime to volunteers. He found that when volunteers saw that an African-American perpetrator was responsible for a crime,
所有穆斯林的名义下行事的。他们并没有说他们是在所有男性的名义下行事的。但穆妮巴的观点是，由于穆斯林是极少数而男性不是，穆斯林的恶行对我们来说就变得显眼了。这也适用于其他少数群体和其他犯罪。斯坦福大学的研究人员香托·延加（Shanto Iyengar）曾做过一项研究，他向志愿者展示了关于地方犯罪的报道。他发现，当志愿者看到一名非洲裔美国肇事者对犯罪负有责任时，
volunteers tended to extrapolate the stigma of criminality to African-Americans as a group. When a white American was responsible for an identical crime, volunteers typically saw the criminal as being an individual, an aberration rather than the rule. Terrorist attacks also trigger another psychological phenomenon, whereas normally we might see that a group of a billion people has enormous diversity, all kinds of different attitudes and political views.
志愿者往往会将犯罪的污名外推到作为一个群体的非裔美国人身上。当一名白人美国人对一起相同的犯罪负有责任时，志愿者通常会将罪犯视为个人，将其视为反常现象而非普遍规律。恐怖袭击还会引发另一种心理现象，即通常情况下，我们可能会认为一个有十亿人的群体拥有巨大的多样性、各种各样不同的态度和政治观点。
Terrorism causes many Americans to view the entire Muslim world as fundamentally homogenous. The idea behind that phenomenon is actually referred to as outgroup homogeneity, and all that is saying is that when the behavior or when the action is involving an outgroup, the group that you don't belong to, then you think that all individuals within that group are, in fact, represented by that particular idea or that particular attribute. So you think that the entire outgroup is homogeneous and they're all the same, they all talk the same, they all behave the same. So if one of them did something, then others must believe and act in the same way as well. The way the media portray terrorism has serious effects not just on our perceptions of Muslims,
恐怖主义导致许多美国人将整个穆斯林世界视为根本上同质的。这种现象背后的理念其实被称为外群体同质性，这一切所要表达的是，当行为或行动涉及到外群体（即你不属于的群体）时，你就会认为该群体内的所有个体，事实上都代表了那个特定的观点或那个特定的属性。因此，你会认为整个外群体是同质的，他们都是一样的，他们说话都一样，行为也一样。所以如果其中一个人做了某事，那么其他人也一定以同样的方式思考和行事。媒体描绘恐怖主义的方式不仅对我们对穆斯林的看法产生了严重影响，
but on the public policies we support. In one study Munibah conducted, volunteers were randomly assigned to watch different clips of Muslims before answering a series of questions. Some volunteers watched news clips in which Muslims were represented as terrorists. Others saw neutral clips about Muslims. A third group saw positive news clips. Clips that showed Muslims volunteering in their communities. And immediately after being exposed to the video clips, we asked them what they think about Muslims in terms of how aggressive they are, how violent they are. But we also asked them
而且对我们所支持的公共政策也产生了严重影响。在穆妮巴进行的一项研究中，志愿者被随机指派去观看不同的穆斯林剪辑片段，然后回答一系列问题。一些志愿者观看了将穆斯林表现为恐怖分子的新闻片段。其他人则观看了关于穆斯林的客观中立片段。第三组观看了积极的新闻片段。展示穆斯林在其社区中做志愿者的片段。在接触到视频片段后，立即询问他们对穆斯林的看法，即他们的攻击性有多强、暴力程度有多高。但我们也询问他们
whether they support various kinds of public policies that are targeting Muslims. And some of these were policies that were more for international countries, so military action, Muslim countries, and other policies were more domestic, so harsher civil restrictions for Muslim Americans. policies were more domestic, so harsher civil restrictions for Muslim Americans. And what we discovered is that participants who were in the negative news condition ended up thinking of Muslims as more aggressive, as more violent, and subsequently supported policies that were targeting Muslims both domestically and internationally compared to those who were in the neutral or positive news condition. So, continuous coverage of Muslims as terrorists is simply activating and strengthening these kinds of associations,
是否支持针对穆斯林的各种公共政策。其中一些是针对国际国家的政策，即对穆斯林国家的军事行动，而其他政策则更具国内性，即针对美国穆斯林的更严厉的民事限制。政策更具国内性，即针对美国穆斯林的更严厉的民事限制。我们发现，处于负面新闻条件下的参与者最终认为穆斯林更具攻击性、更有暴力倾向，并且与处于中立或正面新闻条件下的参与者相比，他们随后支持在国内和国际上针对穆斯林的政策。因此，将穆斯林持续报道为恐怖分子只是在激活和加强这类联想，
ultimately facilitating us to think of Muslims in an aggressive manner and then support harmful behavior towards them. What was striking about this paper was not just that people supported aggressive foreign policy interventions, but they actually supported more aggressive policies toward American citizens who happen to be Muslim. That was actually fascinating for me to know that a lot of Americans are not defensiating between Muslims who are living in other countries versus Muslim Americans who are citizens and who are perhaps their neighbors and their friends. So, we saw people supporting policies such as domestic surveillance, without the consent of Muslim Americans, we saw individuals supporting perhaps that Muslim Americans should not be allowed to vote, that they should have separate and more thorough airport security
最终促使我们以具有攻击性的方式看待穆斯林，进而支持针对他们的有害行为。这篇论文令人瞩目的地方不仅在于人们支持激进的外交政策干预，还在于他们实际上支持对恰好是穆斯林的美国公民采取更激进的政策。这对我来说实际上是很迷人的，因为我了解到许多美国人并没有区分生活在其他国家的穆斯林与身为公民且或许是他们的邻居和朋友的美国穆斯林。因此，我们看到人们支持诸如国内监控之类的政策，在未经美国穆斯林同意的情况下进行监控，我们看到个人支持或许不应该允许美国穆斯林投票、他们应该拥有独立且更彻底的机场安检
lines, that they should be monitored, you know, by the government, their phones should be tapped without their consent. All kinds of unconstitutional policies, we saw Americans supporting those. So when I look at this body of research, what I'm seeing when I step back and look at it is a series of processes that in some ways are driven by fairly understandable and normal human mental processes. The idea that we see aboriginal things or unusual things happening together, we draw correlations between them,
通道、他们应该受到政府的监控（你知道的）、他们的电话应该在未经同意的情况下被窃听。各种违宪的政策，我们看到美国人都在支持这些。因此，当我审视这一系列研究时，当我退后一步审视它时，我看到的是一系列在某些方面由相当可以理解且正常的 ngunit 人类心理过程所驱动的过程。我们看到抽象事物或不寻常事物同时发生，我们在它们之间得出相关性，
we see patterns. And members of the news media, of course, are human beings. And so they gravitate towards certain stories and cover those stories more aggressively, because those stories stick out in their minds, they're more salient. As a result of that kind of media coverage, your research is finding that the attitudes of Americans themselves is changing in a way that becomes hostile to what people living in their communities who are fellow American citizens who happen to be Muslim.
我们看到了规律。当然，新闻媒体的工作人员也是人。因此，他们倾向于某些故事并更具攻击性地报道这些故事，因为这些故事印在他们的脑海中，它们更加显眼。由于这种媒体报道，你的研究发现，美国人自身的态度正在发生变化，变得对生活在其社区中、恰好是穆斯林的同胞美国人充满敌意。
And what is so troubling is that these relatively innocuous psychological biases can eventually have consequences that are anything but innocuous. I think what's really important is to realize that these biases are not just simply something that's in our head, but they are in fact affecting our behaviors and our public policy decisions towards Muslims, both in this country and outside. And also the other side of things, which I've
令人深感不安的是，这些相对无害的心理偏见最终会产生绝非无害的后果。我认为真正重要的是要认识到，这些偏见不仅仅是存在于我们头脑中的东西，它们事实上正在影响着我们对穆斯林的行为以及我们的公共政策决策，无论是在国内还是国外。还有另一个方面，也就是我
actually just recently started looking at, is how the same media representations are influencing Muslim American youth and adolescents who are growing up in this country who identify both as Muslim and as American. It's making them feel as if they cannot be both of those identities, even though there is no reason why they should feel that way. They're having to feel as if they have to choose one over the other because they're being questioned about their American identity on a count of being Muslim. They're having to answer questions about their loyalty, their patriotism as an American, and that is in fact affecting how they think about themselves psychologically, their physical health,
实际上最近才开始研究的方面，即同样的媒体表征是如何影响成长在这个国家、既认同自己是穆斯林又认同自己是美国人的美国穆斯林青少年和少年的。这让他们觉得自己无法同时拥有这两种身份，尽管没有任何理由让他们有这种感觉。他们不得不觉得自己必须在两者之间做出选择，因为他们的美国身份由于身为穆斯林而受到性质上的质疑。他们不得不回答关于他们的忠诚、作为美国人的爱国主义的问题，这实际上正在影响他们对自己心理的看法、他们的身体健康、
their self-esteem, and a host of other important consequences. In some ways, these findings are disheartening. It does feel like a vicious cycle. I asked Muni if she saw any way to combat the psychological biases that terrorism produces. I think one of the greatest ways to break this cycle, and this is supported by both anecdotal evidence, but also research, is contact, increase contact with Muslims, of course, especially when it's positive, tends to decrease reliance on these kinds of biases, and then subsequently
他们的自尊以及其他一系列重要的后果。在某些方面，这些发现令人沮丧。这确实感觉像是一个恶性循环。我问穆妮巴，她是否看到有什么办法可以打击恐怖主义所产生的心理偏见。我认为打破这个循环的最好方法之一，并且这既得到了轶事证据的支持，也得到了研究的支持，那就是接触，增加与穆斯林的接触，当然，尤其是当它是积极的接触时，往往会减少对这些偏见的依赖，从而随后
support for these kinds of harmful actions. So time and time after again, we see that those Americans who have more contact with Muslims and more frequent contact tend to report less of these kinds of biases, tend to not support these kinds of policies as much. They tend to look at the media reports in a more critical manner and they have a very good understanding that what they see in the media is not the entire story. So contact is definitely one of the most important things that we can talk about and we can encourage individuals to pursue in order to break this vicious cycle.
减少对这些有害行为的支持。因此，一次又一次地，我们看到那些与穆斯林接触更多、接触更频繁的美国人倾向于报告较少此类偏见，倾向于不那么支持这些政策。他们倾向于以更加批判的眼光看待媒体报道，并且他们非常清楚地理解，他们在媒体中所看到的并不是全部的故事。因此，接触绝对是我们能够讨论并鼓励个人去追求的最重要的事情之一，以便打破这个恶性循环。
When we come back, how we don't always mean what we say, especially when we're defending free speech. You're listening to Hidden Brain. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantantham. In this segment, we're going to be talking about race and free speech. If you have small kids with you, please know that this segment includes a racial epithet. You often hear a popular claim in the United States.
稍后回来，我们将探讨我们有时并非言行一致，尤其是在我们捍卫言论自由的时候。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。这里是NPR。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。在本节中，我们将讨论种族和言论自由。如果你身边有小孩，请知悉本节包含种族贬义词。在美国，你经常听到一种流行的说法。
We are too politically correct. Some pundits say that political correctness gets in the way of accurately reporting on the threat of terrorism. Political correctness kills. It causes, it will cause death. You can't fight something effectively that you can't talk about. You know, we're now at the point where peace is silencing people and it can have lethal consequences.
我们太政治正确了。一些专家表示，政治正确阻碍了对恐怖主义威胁的准确报道。政治正确会杀人。它导致、它将导致死亡。你无法有效对抗一个你甚至不能谈论的事物。你知道的，我们现在已经到了人们的和平正遭到剥夺的境地，这可能会产生致命的后果。
Others say political correctness infringes on free speech. Is hate speech protected under the Constitution in a word? Yes. There's a fine line between free speech and hate speech. Are they not protected under the Constitution in a word? Yes. There's a fine line between free speech and hate speech. Are they not familiar with the First Amendment? But hold on, we can't have that conversation or any conversation until we both agree that we have the right to say what we believe and that we're not going to be punished for doing that. And I see after the violence and Charlottesville that happened one year ago this week, these questions were
其他人则表示，政治正确侵犯了言论自由。言论自由受宪法保护吗？简而言之：是的。言论自由和仇恨言论之间只有一线之隔。它们难道不受宪法保护吗？简而言之：是的。言论自由和仇恨言论之间只有一线之隔。他们难道不熟悉第一修正案吗？但是等等，我们不能进行那场对话，也不能进行任何对话，直到我们双方都同意我们有权说出我们的信念，并且我们不会因此受到惩罚。我看到在弗吉尼亚州夏洛茨维尔的一年前本周发生的暴力事件之后，这些问题
top of mind. We begin men! White lives men! We begin with the deadly chaos on the streets of Charlottesville, Virginia. It was a weekend of street battles and stark displays of racism. We will be back on the embraces! Photos of enraged white men using the Nazi salute and marching with torches shocked many Americans. And since then, many of us have been doing a lot of soul-searching. Who are we? What do we stand for?
首当其冲。我们开始吧，男人们！白人的生命，男人们！我们从弗吉尼亚州夏洛茨维尔街头的致命混乱开始。那是一个充满街头斗争和赤裸裸种族主义展示的周末。我们将回到拥抱之中！愤怒的白人男性行纳粹礼并举着火炬游行的照片震惊了许多美国人。从那时起，我们许多人一直在进行深刻的反省。我们是谁？我们代表什么？
And as a nation, what do we tolerate? The Constitution upholds the rights of Americans to say almost anything, no matter how distasteful, without censure from legislatures, the police or the courts. Our protections for speech, even hate-filled, vitriolic speech, go further than most nations. In the weeks following Charlottesville, many people made free speech arguments to defend the white supremacists who'd marched.
作为一个国家，我们容忍什么？宪法维护美国人说几乎任何话的权利，无论多么令人厌恶，都不会受到立法机关、警察或法院的谴责。我们对言论（甚至是充满仇恨的、尖酸刻薄的言论）的保护比大多数国家都要走得更远。在夏洛茨维尔事件发生后的几周里，许多人提出了言论自由的论点来为游行的白人至上主义者辩护。
When people defend free speech, what are they really defending? That's a question Chris Krandelist study. He is a professor of psychology at the University of Kansas. We started by talking about an incident that happened a few years ago before Charlottesville. In 2015, members of the Sigma Alpha Epsilon fraternity at the University of Oklahoma were caught on video singing a racist song? They were singing, there will never be a N word in SAE and they were singing happily and clapping along about the exclusion of African Americans from the fraternity.
当人们为言论自由辩护时，他们真正捍卫的是什么？这是堪萨斯大学心理学教授克里斯·克兰德尔（Chris Crandall）研究的一个问题。我们从几年前夏洛茨维尔事件之前发生的一起事件谈起。2015年，俄克拉荷马大学西格玛·阿尔法·埃psilon（SAE）兄弟会的成员被拍到在唱一首歌颂种族主义的歌曲？他们唱着，SAE里永远不会有一个N字头黑人，他们开心地唱着，并为将非洲裔美国人排挤出兄弟会而鼓掌。
The video of the song was put on Facebook and it spread around the campus and the two song leaders of the fraternity who were captured on video were expelled from the university and the fraternity itself was shut down on the campus of the University of Oklahoma and there was really a media firestorm about there singing the song. In the aftermath of the incident one of your graduate students noticed something unusual about the responses to the incident. What did he notice? Yeah, Mark White was following this on the internet and he looked at the tenor of the comments and people were saying, well, this is simply
这首歌的视频被发布到脸书上，并在校园里传开，视频中捕捉到的该兄弟会的两名领唱被学校开除，该兄弟会本身也被关闭在俄克拉荷马大学的校园里，他们唱这首歌引发了一场真正的新闻风暴。事件发生后，你的一名研究生注意到对该事件的反应有些不同寻常。他注意到了什么？是的，马克·怀特（Mark White）一直在互联网上关注这件事，他看了评论的基调，人们说，嗯，这简直是
free speech. These people have a right to say these things because Americans have the right to free speech. But underneath the surface in in the background, or sometimes right at the forefront, it really looked like what people were doing was justifying the content of what was said, not the fact that they have the right to say something freely, but rather that they seem to be justifying the racist speech itself by giving an account, hey free speech, that allowed them to do that without punishment. Now, it's worth pointing out, of course, that the First Amendment protects people against government intrusions on free speech.
言论自由。这些人有权说这些话，因为美国人有言论自由的权利。但在表面之下、背景中，或者有时直接在最前沿，这看起来确实像是人们在做的事情是在为主张的内容正名，而不是因为他们拥有自由说话的权利，而更像是他们通过提供一个借口（嘿，言论自由）来为种族主义言论本身开脱，这使他们能够这样做而免受惩罚。现在，值得指出的是，当然，第一修正案保护人们免受政府对言论自由的干涉。
It doesn't actually prevent private companies or universities from deciding what is or isn't acceptable speech in the workplace or on a college campus. But setting aside that distinction, you conducted an experiment where you had volunteers listen to racially charged commentary, and you evaluated whether they would reach for free speech arguments to defend it. What walked me through the experiment? Yeah, so in one version of the experiment, we did several of these. People read about somebody who wrote something on Facebook that was a deeply racist. For example, a barista wrote on Facebook that the black customers were problematic, that they
它实际上并没有阻止私营公司或大学决定工作场所或大学校园内什么才是可接受的言论。但抛开这种区别不谈，你做了一个实验，让志愿者听取带有种族色彩的评论，并评估他们是否会搬出言论自由的论点来为之辩护。带我了解一下这个实验吧？是的，在实验的一个版本中，我们做了好几个这样的版本。人们读到关于某人在脸书上写了一些极具种族主义色彩的东西。例如，一个咖啡师在脸书上写道，黑人顾客是有问题的，他们
were noisy and rude, and other racially stereotypic actions, and the people in the study read that the person had been fired for posting this racist speech. In the other condition, people read about a guy complaining about customers, but no racial information was given. So the same behavior was described, but the racial element was eradicated. And so the question was, do racial attitudes of our participants determine how much they're going to defend the speaker? In the racialized condition, the more you had negative attitudes towards African Americans,
嘈杂、粗鲁以及其他带有种族刻板印象的行为，研究中的参与者读到这个人因为发表这种种族主义言论而被解雇了。在另一种情况下，人们读到一个关于某人抱怨顾客的故事，但没有给出任何种族信息。因此，描述的是同一种行为，但种族因素被消除了。所以问题是，我们参与者的种族态度是否决定了他们会有多大程度去为发言者辩护？在有种族色彩的情况下，你对非裔美国人的负面态度越多，
the stronger you endorsed free speech as a justification for why the person should have been able to say that without being fired. So that suggests that racial attitudes might be behind free speech defense. But you might say, quite easily, that's simply a correlation. I'm not impressed. Maybe people who have negative racial attitudes are also libertarians, and they believe that free speech is super important, and they're just simply expressing that. The problem with that argument is when you remove the racial content from the story, so in the condition where the guy complains about customers, but there's no racial element,
你就越会支持言论自由，以此作为这个人发表言论而不被解雇的正当理由。这表明种族态度可能是言论自由辩护背后的原因。但你很容易会说，这只是一种相关性。我并不买账。也许持有种族负面态度的人同时也是自由意志主义者，他们认为言论自由极其重要，他们只是在表达这一点。这个论点的漏洞在于，当你从故事中移除种族内容时，也就是在那个抱怨顾客但没有种族元素的版本中，
racial attitudes correlate zero with free speech defense. It seems that people pull them out and deploy them when they're appropriate. So people pull out free speech as a defense when they're defending racist speech, but not when they're defending simply aggressive or negative speech. One of the elements of the study that you conducted asked people about their attitudes about police officers, I find it's not correctly you were measuring controversial speech as it was directed towards a minority group versus controversial speech directed against police officers.
种族态度与言论自由的辩护之间的相关性为零。似乎人们只有在合适的时候才会把它们拿出来并加以运用。因此，人们在为种族主义言论辩护时会把言论自由拿出来作为辩护理由，但在为单纯的攻击性或负面言论辩护时则不会。你所进行的这项研究中的其中一个要素，是询问人们对警官的态度，我觉得我理解得没错，你当时是在衡量针对少数群体的争议性言论与针对警官的争议性言论之间的区别。
Yeah, in the police version, we were interested in not only attitudes towards African-American so somebody said something racist. But we also thought that police might be the exact opposite, that is, people who might be very anti-African-American might be particularly pro-police. So we thought if we used the police, maybe you'd get the opposite effect. And we did, it wasn't as strong, but we did find that the more a person had negative attitudes towards African-Americans, the less they defended anti-police speech. Although in the other condition, the more they defended the free speech of racist commenters.
对的，在警察的版本中，我们不仅关注对非裔美国人的态度——也就是某人说了带有种族色彩的话。但我们也认为警察的情况可能恰恰相反，也就是说，那些非常反非裔美国人的人可能特别支持警察。所以我们认为，如果我们以警察为例，也许会产生相反的效果。我们的确得到了这样的结果，虽然没有那么强烈，但我们确实发现，一个人对非裔美国人的负面态度越多，他们为反警察言论辩护的程度就越低。尽管在另一种情况下，他们越是会为种族主义评论者的言论自由辩护。
So, in other words, if the speech is basically anti-black, someone with high racial animus might say that speech is permissible and the First Amendment free speech grounds, but if the speech is anti-police, the person might say, I don't really agree with this person expressing these kinds of views. So the person is inconsistent in their defense of free speech. That's right. This is what we find is that people are really inconsistent. You also found in the experiment, Chris, that it wasn't just people with racial biases
换句话说，如果这种言论基本上是反黑人的，那么一个带有高度种族敌意的人可能会说，根据第一修正案的言论自由原则，这种言论是允许的；但如果这种言论是反警察的，这个人可能会说，我真的不同意这个人表达这种观点。因此，这个人对言论自由的辩护是前后不一致的。确实如此。我们发现的情况正是，人们的表现确实前后不一致。克里斯，你在实验中还发现，不仅仅是那些带有种族偏见的人，
who were sometimes hypocritical when it came to free speech issues. You also found that people who were low in racial bias were also hypocritical just in the opposite direction. Yes, people who were low in racial prejudice were just as inconsistent in applying the first amendment as a defense, then people who were high in racial prejudice. When they were asked to use the First Amendment to defend racist speech, they actually reduced their willingness to do it. They would defend the free speech of somebody who was complaining
在涉及言论自由的问题时会有时表现得虚伪。你还发现，种族偏见程度低的人也会表现得虚伪，只不过方向完全相反。是的，种族偏见程度低的人在运用第一修正案作为辩护时，其前后不一致的程度，与种族偏见程度高的人不相上下。当被要求利用第一修正案来为种族主义言论辩护时，他们实际上降低了自己这样做的意愿。他们会以平均水平去捍卫某个抱怨
about their customers or police at an average level, but when it became racialized, the low-racist people actually walked away from the First Amendment defense. They went substantially lower. This suggests that when people are using the free speech defense, they know what they're doing, because the high-racists use it in defense of racist speech and the low racists drop it like a hot potato and say, no, no, no, no, no, we're not defending this speech with First Amendment. But they would defend a barista who's complaining about his or her customers or the police. When you found people defending the racist speech on First Amendment grounds, on freedom of expression grounds,
其顾客或警察的普通人的言论自由，但当事情带有种族色彩时，那些种族偏见低的人实际上却抛弃了第一修正案的辩护。他们的意愿大幅下降。这表明，当人们使用言论自由作为辩护时，他们心知肚明自己在做什么，因为偏见程度高的人用它来为种族主义言论辩护，而偏见程度低的人则像扔烫手山芋一样把它扔掉，并说：不，不，不，不，我们绝不用第一修正案来为这种言论辩护。但他们会为一个抱怨顾客或警察的咖啡师辩护。当你们发现有人以第一修正案为由、以言论自由为由为种族主义言论辩护时，
is this because people may have at some level felt bad about themselves? Chris, they felt bad that the person who has views similar to their own is being punished in some way and they're trying to defend that person as a way to defend themselves? That's exactly what we thought was going on and when we started showing these studies, everybody would nod when we say, and so maybe they're defending themselves. But we did several studies where we tried to find out if people's self-esteem was attacked by this, if they needed help to feel good about themselves, and we could never find evidence that people were defending themselves. What we found evidence for was that people were defending their right to say things.
这是不是因为人们在某种程度上对自身感到内疚？克里斯，他们是否感到内疚，因为观点与他们相似的人受到了某种惩罚，于是他们试图通过辩护来保护这个人，以此来保护他们自己？这正是我们当时的看法，当我们开始展示这些研究时，每个人在我们说“所以也许他们是在为自己辩护”时都会点头称是。但我们做了好几项研究，试图找出人们的自尊心是否因此受到攻击，他们是否需要通过辩护来感觉良好，而我们从未找到证据证明人们是在为自己辩护。我们找到证据支持的是，人们是在捍卫自己说话的权利。
They were defending the speech so that their future speech would be protected. They wanted to create a world where this kind of prejudicial speech was acceptable for them to say, for others to say, in the future. How would you respond to people who might say, you know, let's look under the hood of Chris Crandell's brain. Isn't it possible he's just, you know, a lefty academic who's coming up with research findings that endorse his own pre-existing views
他们是在捍卫言论本身，以便他们自己未来的言论能够受到保护。他们想要创造这样一个世界：在未来，这种偏见性的言论对他们自己而言、对其他人而言都是可以接受的。你会如何回应那些可能会说这样话的人——你知道的，让我们剖析一下克里斯·克兰德尔的大脑。难道有没有这种可能，他只是个左翼学者，炮制出符合他对世界如何运作的既定看法的研究结果？
of how the world works? I think that some of that criticism would probably land. I am sort of a lefty academic. I'm a little bit more centrist, I suppose, but we were interested in studying prejudice because prejudice is a particular social problem. It shows up all around the country. It affects people's lives. And so we studied that. But people would be inconsistent about, for example, being environmentalist and failing to recycle or going too fast in the right-hand lane of a highway. People are inconsistent all the time, and they manage to get over that pretty easily, mostly, by being unaware of it or not paying attention
我认为这种批评在一定程度上是切中要害的。我确实算是一个左翼学者。我想我更偏向中间派一些，但我们之所以对研究偏见感兴趣，是因为偏见是一个特殊的社会问题。它在全国各地无处不在。它影响着人们的生活。所以我们才去研究它。但人们在其他事情上也会前后不一致，例如，一边标榜自己是环保主义者却不进行垃圾分类，或者在高速公路的最右侧车道超速行驶。人们一直在表现得前后不一致，而他们通常通过无意识或不太关注，
to it too much. Not only are we inconsistent, we take cues from how other people behave. To explain this, we need to take what might seem like a bit of a detour to talk about a toy. If you're a parent, maybe your kid has one of those inflatable punching bag toys, a clown or a shark, or like the one in this YouTube video, an inflatable Spider-Man. What have you got me? These toys, which are known as Bobo dolls, were used in a famous psychology experiment in the 1960s. The researcher Albert Bandura had kids watch as a person repeatedly hit a Bobo doll with a hammer. I let researcher Chris Crandell pick up the story from here. Now, what Banderah had his children watch was somebody who came in, went and grabbed a hammer,
就能相当轻松地克服这种矛盾。我们不仅前后不一致，还会从其他人的行为中获取暗示。为了解释这一点，我们需要绕一点看似有些迂回的弯路来谈谈一个玩具。如果你是个父母，也许你的孩子也有那种充气不倒翁玩具，一个小丑、一条鲨鱼，或者就像这个YouTube视频里一样，一个充气的蜘蛛侠。你给我准备了什么？这些被称为波波玩偶的玩具，在20世纪60年代的一项著名的心理学实验中被使用过。研究人员阿尔伯特·班杜拉让孩子们观看一个人用锤子反复击打一个波波玩偶。接下来，我让研究人员克里斯·克兰德尔接着讲这个故事。那么，班杜拉让他的孩子们观看的是，一个人走进来，拿了一把锤子，
straddled the bobo doll so that it was lying on the ground, and then hit it in the face with a hammer, saying, punch him in the face, hit him with a hammer. Afterwards, sometimes what he called the model, the person doing the punching, was punished, sometimes nothing happened at all, sometimes they were rewarded. The children were then put in a room filled with toys, and over in the corner, a bobo doll, and elsewhere in the room, a hammer. The kids who had seen the model either have no consequence at all, or be rewarded quickly when over. Grab the hammer, got the bobo doll into the middle of the room, and started immediately pounding
骑在波波玩偶身上使其倒在地上，然后用锤子砸它的脸，嘴里喊着“打他的脸，用锤子打他”。随后，有时他所说的“模范”（也就是那个进行殴打的人）会受到惩罚，有时什么事也没发生，有时则会受到奖励。然后，孩子们被带到一个摆满玩具的房间里，角落里放着一个波波玩偶，房间的其他地方则放着一把锤子。那些看到模范没有受到任何惩罚、或者很快受到奖励的孩子们跑了过去。他们抓起锤子，把波波玩偶拖到房间中央，开始对着它的脸一阵猛砸，
it about the face with the hammer and repeating punch them in the face, hit him with the hammer. The kids who had seen the model be punished did not do this at all. But here's the trick. Bandero wisely said at the end of this, you know, if you saw something in that video that interested you, you should know you won't be punished for this. At this point, a majority of the kids get a look of glee on their face, run over, grab the bobo doll, grab the hammer,
并且重复着“打他的脸，用锤子打他”。而那些看到模范受到惩罚的孩子们则完全没有这样做。但关键的戏码在这里。班杜拉在实验结束时明智地说道：“你知道的，如果你在视频中看到了让你感兴趣的东西，你应该知道你不会因此受到惩罚。”就在这时，大多数孩子的脸上露出了兴奋的表情，他们跑过去，抓起波波玩偶，抓起锤子，
and start beating it about the face and straddling it, and doing what they'd seen the model do. The moral of the story is that we learn from what people do and sometimes we don't do it. We may want to punch the bobble doll, but we know that we'll be punished for it. If somebody comes in and says, it's okay, you can use that hammer and bobble doll.
开始对着它的脸一阵猛砸，骑在它身上，做着他们刚才看到模范做过的动作。这个故事的寓意是，我们从人们的行为中学习，但有时我们并没有付诸行动。我们可能想去殴打波波玩偶，但我们知道我们会因此受到惩罚。如果有人走进来并说：“没关系，你可以使用那把锤子和波波玩偶。”
They will gleefully run and grab the tools and start beating the face of the bobo doll So what do Albert Bandora and the bobo dolls have to do with free speech? The link here has to do with social norms and what's permissible and not permissible Chris Krandel conducted a study in the lead up to the 2016 presidential election. He looked at both liberals and conservatives and asked them a series of questions. We were interested in what prejudices people had and we also wanted to ask them what they thought
他们就会兴高采烈地跑过去抓起工具，开始殴打波波玩偶的脸。那么，阿尔伯特·班杜拉和波波玩偶与言论自由有什么关系呢？这里的联系与社会规范以及什么是允许的、什么是不允许的有关。克里斯·克兰德尔在2016年总统大选前夕进行了一项研究。他调查了自由派和保守派，并向他们提出了了一系列问题。我们对人们怀有什么偏见很感兴趣，同时也想问问他们，在他们看来，
it was okay to express in the world. So we asked them about Muslims, Canadians, blind people, immigrants, women and and we ask them how do you feel about them on a zero to 100 scale and the lower the number, the less you like them. But other people, we ask them what do you think is okay to express in the US? So we were able to find out not only what people say they have as prejudices, but what they think is acceptable to express in the US. You brought the same people back after the election, and you asked them the same questions. What did they say?
在世界上表达哪些观点是可以接受的。所以我们询问了他们关于穆斯林、加拿大人、盲人、移民、女性的看法，并且我们以零到一百的数字询问他们对这些群体的感受，数字越低，代表他们越不喜欢这些群体。但对于其他人，我们问他们：你认为在美国表达什么观点是可以接受的？因此，我们不仅能够了解人们口中的偏见是什么，还能了解他们认为在美国什么是可以表达的。你在大选后又把这批人找了回来，并向他们提出了相同的问题。他们是怎么说的？
For both Trump conservative supporters and Clinton more liberal supporters, we found that they thought the nation had changed substantially in what it was okay to express as a prejudice. For the groups that Trump had actually targeted in his campaign, Muslims, I think Islam hates us. Mexicans. They're bringing drugs. They're bringing crime. They're rapists.
无论是特朗普的保守派支持者，还是克林顿的自由派支持者，我们都发现他们认为，国家在哪些偏见是可以表达的这一点上已经发生了实质性的改变。对于特朗普在竞选期间实际针对的群体——穆斯林（我认为伊斯兰教仇恨我们）、墨西哥人（他们带来了毒品、犯罪，他们是强奸犯）、
Illegal immigrants. They beat us at the border. People are flowing through. Drugs are coming across, pouring across. Fat people. Only Rosie O'Donnell. There was a significant increase in how acceptable it was to express prejudice towards them.
非法移民（他们在边境击溃了我们，人们源源不断地涌入，毒品正跨越边境倾泻而入）、肥胖人群（只有罗茜·欧唐纳）。人们对表达针对他们的偏见的接受度有了显着增加。
The interesting thing is there was no change in the acceptability of prejudice towards groups that Trump had not aimed his prejudice at blind people, Canadians, and so on. What do you draw from the experiment, Chris? I mean, it seems remarkable that in a matter of weeks, you know, from stage one to stage two of your experiment, people's views of what they consider acceptable are changing. Yes, it was really only about two weeks and we don't think that anybody changed their hearts and minds in that time. What we think is that the election of Donald
有趣的是，对于特朗普没有将其偏见对准的群体（如盲人、加拿大人等），人们对针对他们的偏见的接受度没有任何改变。克里斯，你从这个实验中得出什么结论？我的意思是，这似乎很神奇，在短短几周内——从你实验的第一阶段到第二阶段——人们对什么是可接受的看法竟然在发生改变。是的，这实际上大约只花了两个星期，而且我们不认为有任何人在这段短短的时间里改变了内心和想法。我们认为的是，唐纳德·特朗普的
Trump changed people's understanding of what America felt. The election of Donald Trump, despite all of his overt expressions of prejudice, meant that it must be okay in America to have these prejudices. And so their scores on the acceptability of prejudice for the Trump-targeted groups went up, but not the ones he didn't target. The interesting thing about this is that people's own prejudices did not go up following their sense that America accepted it. And in fact, to a small degree, our participants, both Trump supporters and Clinton supporters, said they went down a little bit in prejudice, just a little bit.
当选改变了人们对美国人真实感受的理解。尽管唐纳德·特朗普公开表达了各种偏见，但他的当选意味着，在美国拥有这些偏见一定是件可以接受的事。因此，他们对特朗普所针对的群体的偏见接受度得分上升了，而他未针对的群体的得分则没有上升。有趣的是，在人们感受到美国社会对此予以接受之后，他们自身的偏见并没有上升。事实上，在某种程度上，我们的参与者——无论是特朗普的支持者还是克林顿的支持者——都表示他们的偏见甚至略有下降，哪怕只是一点点。
And what we think is going on is that they looked around, saw the acceptability of prejudice, saw in America how much there really was, more than they thought, and they said to themselves, oh, I'm less prejudice than I thought I was. I must be okay because there's a lot more prejudice out there than I thought. Did it strike you as remarkable that things change so quickly? I mean, I think most of us think about social norms as being relatively stable and enduring things. They're the things that are acceptable in a country or a society.
我们认为发生的情况是，他们环顾四周，看到了偏见被接受的现实，看到了美国社会中这种偏见的普遍程度比他们想象的要高得多，于是他们对自己说：“哦，我其实比自己想象的要少一些偏见。我肯定没问题，因为外面的偏见可比我想象的多多了。”事情变化得如此之快，这有没有让你感到震惊？我的意思是，我想我们大多数人认为社会规范是相对稳定和持久的。它们是一个国家或社会中被认为可以接受的事物。
One day, I'm probably going to be the same things that are acceptable tomorrow or next week. And you're finding there was a dramatic change. Was it just the scale of the election, the fervor of the election that you think might have made the difference, or do you think that actually social norms actually are very valuable, and they can change fairly quickly? You're right that most norms are stable, especially ones that have been around a long time and are as public as prejudice norms in the US. But this is a little bit different. First of all, the presidential election and coverage of Trump and prejudice was massive. The mass media
今天被接受的事物，明天或下周大概率还是被接受的事物。而你们发现这里发生了戏剧性的变化。你认为仅仅是大选的规模、大选狂热造成了这种差异，还是你认为实际上社会规范非常脆弱，并且它们能够相当迅速地改变？你说得对，大多数规范都是稳定的，尤其是那些存在了很久、并且像美国的偏见规范那样公开的规范。但这有点不同。首先，总统大选以及对特朗普和偏见的报道规模极其巨大。大众媒体
and personal discussion over Trump and his discussion of racial groups, immigrant groups, fat people and so on was a huge intervention. Second of all, people were surprised that the American public approved of it by electing him. Now, of course, it wasn't the popular vote, but still winning the presidency alone is likely to have an effect on social norms. But one key difference with this social norm is that there is a large number of Americans who are suppressing their prejudice, who were holding it back, who wouldn't say what
以及围绕特朗普及其对少数族裔、移民群体、肥胖人群等言论的个人讨论，是一次巨大的干预。其次，人们对美国公众通过选举批准这种行为感到惊讶。当然，这并不是指普选票，但仅仅是赢得总统宝座就足以对社会规范产生影响。但这种社会规范的一个关键区别在于，有大量美国人一直在压抑他们的偏见，一直在克制自己，他们不会说出
they really felt because they knew it would be punished. This is what is meant by political correctness. People have attitudes that are negative, but they don't say them out loud because they know that they're unpopular. The election of Trump removed the suppression. It was a key that opened up the floodgates just a little bit for people who had been suppressing their feelings a lot. And that's why the number of hate crimes seems to have jumped right after the election, not before when the speech was all there, but after when the nation seemed to approve of Trump's prejudices.
他们真实感受的话，因为他们知道这会招致惩罚。这就是“政治正确”的含义。人们怀有负面的态度，但他们不会大声说出来，因为他们知道这些态度不受欢迎。特朗普的当选解除了这种压抑。它就像一把钥匙，为那些长期压抑自己感受的人打开了洪水闸门的一小部分。这就是为什么仇恨犯罪的数量似乎在大选结束后立即激增——不是在大选前那些言论满天飞的时候，而是在大选后、当全国上下似乎都在认可特朗普的偏见的时候。
So it's almost, you know, a parallel, this eerie parallel to the Bandoorestety, because what you're saying is it's not enough just to see the model strike the Bobo doll with the hammer. That isn't what actually causes the children to then imitate the adult. It's actually seeing what happens to the model. After he or she does that to the Bobo doll, does the model get rewarded, does the model get punished? It's that action that then determines whether the children imitate the model or don't imitate the model. That's exactly right. It's not so much what's in your head and heart as it is you looking around and seeing what's acceptable, seeing what's okay, seeing what people will tolerate, and the election changed people's notion of what was tolerable. I'm wondering if this research has any connection with some other work that you've done looking
所以，这几乎就像是一个平行事件，与班杜拉实验有着不可思议的相似之处，因为你所说的意思是，仅仅看到模范用锤子击打波波玩偶是不够的。那并不是促使孩子们随后模仿成年人的原因。真正的原因是看到模范的遭遇。在模范对波波玩偶做出那种举动之后，模范是受到了奖励还是受到了惩罚？正是这个后续动作，决定了孩子们是去模仿模范，还是不模仿模范。完全正确。这与其说是存在于你的脑海和内心中的东西，不如说是你环顾四周，看到什么是可以接受的、什么是没问题的、人们能容忍什么，而这场选举改变了人们对什么是可容忍的观念。我在想，这项研究是否与你所做的另一项关于 authenticity（真实性）的研究有什么联系？
at the question of authenticity. You know, you found that we all crave politicians who are authentic and certainly that was one of the big appeals of Donald Trump. But sometimes you've argued or your research has found that authenticity is a way to express more subtle feelings. Yeah, people said that Donald Trump was very authentic and we wondered there's really is a way to express more subtle feelings. Yeah, people said that Donald Trump was very authentic, and we wondered, there's really two ways that that could go.
你知道的，你发现我们都渴望真实的政治家，而这无疑是唐纳德·特朗普的一大魅力所在。但有时你曾辩称或你的研究发现，真实性其实是表达更微妙感受的一种方式。是的，人们说唐纳德·特朗普非常真实，我们当时在想，这其实有两种可能的发展方向。
One is that we think he's authentic because he says things that are unpopular, and by saying things that are counter to the social norms, we see that he's revealing something about himself that's different from every other person. To say that you like ice cream is to reveal very little about yourself, but to say that I don't think ice cream is any good reveals quite a lot about you because it's so unusual and so atypical. With the case of prejudice, we wondered if maybe people thought he was authentic because he was saying these horrible things that they thought were horrible, but holy cow, at least he says it.
一种是我们认为他真实，是因为他说了一些不受欢迎的话，而通过说出违背社会规范的话，我们发现他展现出了一些与其他人截然不同的自我。说你喜欢冰淇淋，其实暴露了你很少的个人信息；但说“我觉得冰淇淋一点也不好吃”，则能暴露你相当多的信息，因为这太不同寻常、太不典型了。以偏见为例，我们当时在想，也许人们认为他真实，是因为他说出了这些可怕的话——尽管人们认为这些话很可怕，但天哪，至少他敢说出来。
I don't frankly have time for total political correctness. And to be honest with you, this country doesn't have time either. That's one possibility. The other possibility is exactly the opposite. And that is authenticity is really just code words for saying you are saying the prejudice that I have. An authentic person is somebody who says what I feel when I can't say it myself. Trump supporters who listen to this critique might say that they are being boxed into a corner.
坦白说，我没有时间去搞什么绝对的政治正确。说实话，这个国家也没有这个时间。这是一种可能性。另一种可能性则恰恰相反。那就是，“真实性”实际上只是一句暗语，意思是：你在表达我内心怀有的偏见。一个真实的人，就是一个自我无法宣泄时，能替我把心中感受说出来的人。听了这个批评的特朗普支持者可能会说，他们被逼入了绝角。
Just because they believe that Trump is authentic or they believe in free speech protections doesn't automatically mean that they're closet races. That's a fair criticism. The reason we are interested in Trump is that we are interested in trying to explain how Americans were able to tolerate his racism. I think that most of us in the social science community were surprised that Trump was elected not because of his politics, but because his racism, his attitudes towards immigrants, his anti-fat prejudice, his misogyny didn't seem to stop most Americans or many Americans from voting for him.
仅仅因为他们相信特朗普是真实的，或者他们信仰言论自由的保护，并不自动意味着他们就是深柜种族主义者。这是一个合理的批评。我们之所以对特朗普感兴趣，是因为我们试图解释美国人是如何能够容忍他的种族主义的。我认为社会科学界的我们大多数人对特朗普当选感到惊讶，倒不是因为他的政治立场，而是因为他的种族主义、他对移民的态度、他对肥胖人群的偏见、他的厌女症，似乎并没有阻止大多数美国人或许多美国人投票给他。
And that's the question that we're trying to explain. It's not particularly a liberal or conservative thing to be hypocritical. It's a very human thing to do that. But the public policy implications for prejudice is why we chose to look at Trump and authenticity in this way. Where does the research go from here? And are you still trying to figure out ways to study if social norms are continuing to change as we move further and further from the 2016 election. We've been following some of the same people that we followed at the election. And what we have found is that the norms for prejudice are becoming more tolerant of prejudice,
这就是我们试图解释的问题。表现得虚伪并不是自由派或保守派特有的事情，这是非常人性化的行为。但为了公共政策对偏见的影响，正是我们选择以这种方式看待特朗普和真实性的原因。这项研究接下来将走向何方？随着我们离2016年大选越来越远，你们是否仍在寻找方法来研究社会规范是否还在继续改变？我们一直在追踪大选时调查过的一些同一批人。我们发现的是，人们对偏见的规范变得越来越能容忍偏见，
even beyond what Trump targeted. So the bad news is that it seems that all prejudices are becoming somewhat more acceptable as the course goes on. Chris Krandel is a psychologist at the University of Kansas. Chris, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. This week's episode was produced by Raina Cohen, Lucy Perkins, and Maggie Penman. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Pat Shah, Thomas Liu and Laura Quarelle. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. Anya Grunman is NPR's vice president for programming. For more
甚至超出了特朗普曾经针对的范围。所以坏消息是，随着时间的推移，所有的偏见似乎都在变得在某种程度上更加可以接受。克里斯·克兰德尔是堪萨斯大学的心理学家。克里斯，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，香卡。本周的节目由雷娜·科恩、露西·珀金斯和玛吉·彭曼制作。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、帕特·沙阿、托马斯·刘和劳拉·夸雷尔。我们的监管制片人是塔拉·博伊尔。安雅·格伦曼是NPR节目制作副总裁。想要了解更多
hidden brain, you can follow the show on Facebook and Twitter and make sure to subscribe to our podcast. I'm Shankar Vedantham. Thanks for listening to Hidden Brain. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
关于《隐藏的大脑》的内容，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注本节目，并务必订阅我们的播客。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。感谢收听《隐藏的大脑》。下周见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。